Hey.
How are you?
Lyric.
Are they coming for build it, Rick?
They are not, I believe. I didn't check with him so far, if I remember correctly.
Let's start the conversation with it. Let's get the registered.
Hi, Rob.
Morning.
Morning, Rob.
How are you guys?
Good, how are you?
We are good.
Good, yourself?
You see a new face, Rob. So Aman is going through a minor surgery, or rather he has gone through it already during the weekend. So he's currently in a recovery phase. Kip is also one of the technical team leads of in my team, similar to Aman. So yeah, we wanted to.
Mm.
at least have a touch point right and have the conversation going. And yeah, once Aman is back, he will be able to take over.
Okay.
Yep.
Great, how long do you think it'll be out?
Just for this week.
Okay.
Yeah.
Very good. Max can't join us today. He's addressing an urgent client issue, so...
Sure.
Yeah.
A little bit of disarray this morning, I guess, Monday morning.
Kour.
Mondays and Fridays, yeah.
Great, so over to you, Rick.
Yep, perfect. Before starting on our the regular agenda, Rob, I just want to check, like, are you got chance to register for build it even that's coming up in August?
I have not, but I and Brent and Michelle from our organization are, they'll be there.
Okay, perfect, perfect, perfect. So I think we are good there, Amit.
But yes, Kip, if you can go ahead and maybe start with the deck.
Parth.
Yeah, so again, I would like to start with a quick introduction. So my name is Kip. I am a technical team leader with ITBD by Design, and it's been more than 6 1/2 years with this organization. And yeah.
Great, welcome.
So yeah, thank you. And just wanted to check how things are moving with the Sterling.
Um...
It was a good week. He participated in several technical projects, and so that was good. And we are, thus far, we are pleased with his technical aptitude. That's all going good.
Mhm.
Okay.
We're lining up projects for the future.
He's going to help us initially with the internal conversion on our spam software. So that's primarily what he'll be doing this week.
Yeah, *****.
Yeah, so I had a word with him and so he will be working on the that email protection email security in key to earlier it was a perception point, right? Yeah, yeah, OK, cool.
Mhm.
Perception point, yeah, yeah.
And he's also working on some file server migration project as well.
S.
Yeah, the App River to 365.
I know.
Yeah.
So, that's still the planning pages, but we hope to get that ironed out.
Kip.
And he's also working on his training and certification on SC300 and MS102. Those things are in progress.
Hoh.
Yep.
Well, I understand he's ready to sit for MS 102, is that right?
Is ready to take that test.
Um...
No, I because yeah, he has already worked on this previously as well. So there won't be any challenges. So you just need to brush up a few things and then he will be ready.
Okay, so maybe that's something that we can get scheduled soon.
Yeah, right, right. So anything apart?
Couple weeks out.
Kour.
Yeah, I think Kip, if you can check if he is already ready in terms of dates, et cetera, that he wants to appear or if he has kept it open ended yet. And we can get back to you, Rob, with that.
Yep.
Sure, sure, I will definitely check that, yeah.
That'd be great.
Okay, anything apart from this that you think he needs to work on or any areas of improvement maybe?
Not that I'm aware of, no, no.
Okay, yeah, I know he's pretty closely working with Max, and Max is not able to join today due to the client issue, but that's completely understandable.
Every, everything's.
Hoh.
OK, I guess then we are good on that part. Anything from you, Amit or Rick?
No, I am good too. Just checking in, Rick, we were able to agree to the KPIs or is this something that we will discuss?
I think, I think we we did connected with Rob and team. I think we finalized the KPIs and everything. Aman do have those, yeah.
Okay.
Awesome, thank you.
We have a final list of KPIs. We agreed to wait another two or three weeks to formalize the KPIs.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay. Okay. Sounds good.
Somebody's working on.
Bye.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Okay, and again, we have our Teams channel open to you all. So any issues, concerns, you don't have to wait for these calls. The weekly connects, you can reach out to us anytime and we are more than happy to help.
Great.
Thank you, guys.
All right. Thank you, Rob. Thank you.
Alright.
Yeah, thank you, Rob. Have a wonderful rest of the day. Yeah, and week. Bye.
Thank you, Rob. Have a great day.
Cheers, bye-bye.
Take care.